so i have the graph of y is equal to f
of t here our horizontal axis is in
terms of time in terms of seconds and
this type of function is often described
as a square wave and we see that it is a
periodic function that it completes one
cycle every two pi seconds and so we
could say its period is equal to
two pi if we want to put the units we
could say two pi
two pi
seconds
per cycle we could write it like that we
could also just write s for seconds and
its frequency is going to be 1 over that
so we could write its frequency
its frequency is equal to 1 over 2 pi
cycles
cycles per second cycles per second it
can also be described as hertz and what
we're going to explore in this video is
can we take a periodic function like
this and represent it as an infinite sum
of sines and cosines of different
periods or different frequencies so to
write that out a little bit more clearly
can we take our f of t
so can we take our f of t
and write it as the sum of sines and
cosines
so can we write it so it's going to be
some let's say baseline constant that'll
shift it up or down and as we'll see
that's going to be based on the average
value of the function over over over one
period so a sub zero and then let's
start adding some periodic functions
here
and so let's take a sub 1
times cosine
of t
now why am i starting with cosine of t
and i could also add a sine of t so plus
plus
b sub 1
plus b sub 1 of sine of t why am i
starting with cosine of t and sine of t
well if our original function has a
period of 2 pi and i just set up this
one so it does have a period of 2 pi
well it would make sense that it would
involve some functions that have periods
of 2 pi and these weights will tell us
how much they involve it if a1 is much
larger than b1 it says okay this is this
has a lot more of cosine of t in it than
it has of sine of t in it and that by
itself isn't going to describe this
function because we know what this would
look like this would look like a very
clean sinusoid not like a square wave
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to add we're going to add
sinusoids of frequencies that are
multiples of these frequencies so let's
add
let's add
a sub 2
so another weighting coefficient times
cosine of two t this has this has a
frequency of one over two pi this has
twice the frequency this has a frequency
of one over pi and then a sub three
times cosine of three t and i'm going to
keep going on and on and on forever and
i'm going to do the same thing with the
signs so plus
b2
sine
of 2t
plus
b3
sine
of
3t
and you might be saying well okay this
this seems like a fun little
mathematical exercise but why do folks
even do this
well this was ex
first explored and that they're named
series like this infinite series where
you represent something by essentially
weighted sines and cosines this was
explored originally by fourier and
they're called fourier series
and they were interesting to him
in the study of differential equations
because a lot of differential equations
are are can
are easy to solve when you involve sines
and cosines but not as obvious to solve
when you have more general functions
like maybe a square wave here but if you
could represent that square wave as sums
of sines and cosines then all of a
sudden you might be able to find more
general solutions to your differential
equations another really interesting
thing about this and this is really the
foundation of signal processing it's
very used it's heavily used that
electrical engineering is you can view
these coefficients as they are they're
weights on these cosines and sines but
another way to think about it is they
tell you how much of different
frequencies that this function contains
so for example if a1 is much bigger than
a2 then that tells you that that
function contains a lot more of the one
over two pi hertz frequency than the one
over pi frequency or maybe a2 or maybe
a3 is bigger than a1 or a2 and so you
start you can start to say hey this this
helps us think of a function not just in
terms of the time domain which f of t
does but it can start bringing us to
saying well how much do we have of each
frequency and as we'll see with fourier
series and eventually fourier transforms
that's going to give us get us into the
frequency domain where we can start
doing some signal processing so we're
going to explore all of that in future
videos
in order to understand how we can
actually find these coefficients we're
going to review a little bit of our
trigonometry especially integrating trig
functions and then we're going to solve
for these and we're going to see how
good we can approximate our function f